let's say it's not exotic phenomenon  let's say it is Chinese drones or  Portuguese I don't know why we always  have to stigmatize that those nefarious  enemies trying to so they're harassing  and so you wouldn't want to make it so  that the next time an F-35 pilot is out  there that she's not gonna report it  right so you don't want to stigmatize it  I'm all for that I'm all for reporting  these incidents because I think uh the  more that they can be reported the more  we can clear it was actually going on  because I think there are very real  issues here that needs to be figured out  they should have followed this out they  should have tried to figure out what was  going on and maybe they did either there  was a failure there in doing that or  they already knew what it was I think he  is probably the former they probably  just didn't take him seriously